الاب هو قطع من
القلب الضرب ضربه بضربه بالارض حس بضرب
بقلبي وعزب وتعبه عمره 55 سنه 65 ما بيحسن
يضرب بالفاز ضربه ب طلع بساعه الصبح الحمد
لله بس ابوي بعمره مام جوعان بعمره بس
بردانين بقول لك بردانين لو ماش حد لم
الخبز ما ننام جوعانين ما ينام جوعان
العالم عاشي فوق نحنا تحت والعالم كلها
تكره الفق مضبوط ولا لا ب كله خلقه الله
هو الله رزقه والفقير الله بزقه صعب الفقر
بس اما الغنيه تفرق معه اذا ما الله سوا
مه ما بحس تيجي لمرحله توصل للمس وتنام
جوع انت ولا مره بحياتك تربط السعو الجوع
ونمشي حالنا بالليل ناكل بصله بناكل خبزه
ايش من كان مشرب المهم منجو بس بالبرد مثل
السكاكين اغص في بطن الوح في جسمه بقطع
البرد البرد صعب انا بتحمل اخوات الصغار
ما بتحمل ابوي ما بتحمل امي ما بتحمل
l